olá pessoal é eu sou robson gonçalves
economista e apaixonado pela
neurociência as suas aplicações
a minha história com a neurociência ela
começou por volta de 2011
e eu devo muito do que eu vou falar aqui
com vocês hoje sobre o urbanismo a uma
colega minha fundação getúlio vargas que
coordena comigo o curso de neurobusiness
da fgv que andré de paiva ela assim a
arquiteta e urbanista em neuro urbanista
parece um tema estranho falar de solidão
nas grandes cidades afinal de contas
como é que alguém pode se sentir sozinho
numa cidade como são paulo que tem 11
milhões de habitantes
o fato é que muita gente se sente
sozinho nas grandes cidades
esse meu caso com a neurociência começou
em paralelo com uma outra história
eu estava pesquisando na verdade a minha
árvore genealógica pela linha materna eu
queria que a anormalidade portuguesa
chegassem até a minha filha júlia
e aí eu descobri uma história muito
fascinante que a história da minha
bisavó margarida minha bisavó margarida
ela morava numa cidade que é pequena até
hoje em baião lá no norte de portugal e
eu fiquei tão encantada com a história
dela descobrir a data em que ela saiu de
baião descobrir o navio é o vapor onde
onde ela embarcou com o marido ea filha
pequena a na cidade do porto e descobrir
registros dela a museu da imigração
quintão em santos aqui em são paulo e eu
fui recuperando na verdade a história
dessa minha família da linha materna até
meados do século 18
e aí eu me perguntei o que será que
tinha feito a margarida sair lá de
bayamón àquela aldeia vizinha o norte de
portugal e eu descobri que esses meus
ancestrais na família ribeiro eles
ficaram 150 anos ao redor de aldeias
como essa em portugal
eles se casavam assim cumprimos
distantes a repetiam os nomes então eu
pegava o nome de seu bisavô colocava no
seu filho assim às vezes pensando no
génio de algumas primas minhas acho que
essa história de casar com prima pode
não ser uma boa
e aí ela saiu de lá em 1888 e acabou se
fixando depois de idas e vindas 1
taubaté ea uma guarida morreu lá por
volta da década de 1950
e aí eu com o neto dela vivo nessa
metrópole uma cidade como são paulo com
11 milhões de habitantes que têm a mesma
população do país inteiro de portugal e
aí fiquei me perguntando o que será que
se passou na cabeça dava guarida para
deixar baião e e vir aqui para o brasil
então na neurociência encontrei uma
pista a solidão nada mais é mesmo quando
você está cercado de muitas pessoas do
que um não pertencimento
você acha que você não pertence àquele
lugar você acha que você não pertence
àquele grupo a você não deveria estar
ali
e aí você vai procurar esse
pertencimento em outro lugar em outro
grupo a em outra situação pois é no
cérebro o pertencimento
ele tem muito a ver com o sistema
límbico ele tem muito a ver com uma
substância chamada oxitocina
quando você está no grupo é com qual
você se identifica
pode ser a sua família se você se
identifica com ela ela pode ser o seu
time de futebol quando você está
assistindo uma partida ao seu cérebro
está cheio de oxitocina então você tem
aquela sensação de que eu deveria estar
aqui
eu pertenço a esse grupo eu me
identifico com aquela pessoa a com
aquelas pessoas
mas aí a questão é então que tipo de
angústia urbana a é gerada quando você
está se sentindo não pertencendo a um
grupo ou um lugar e você está cercado
por 11 milhões de pessoas só parou para
refletir sobre uma coisa eu acho que eu
nunca estive com nenhum de vocês que
estão no seu auditório
vocês são estranhos pra mim num certo
sentido e é muito provável que eu nunca
mais vai ver vocês ao longo da minha
vida
então esse sentimento de que você estava
uma multidão de estranhos pessoas que
estão passando por você e não vou voltar
mas está muito ligado a uma baixa
actividade do sistema límbico a uma
baixa produção de ocitocina copa
margarida morreu há por volta de lá no
início da década de 1950 um artista
americano chamado eduardo romper
ele estava é essa a forma de expressão
aqui na pintura há muito realista muito
modernista também refletindo exatamente
esse tipo de sentimento pessoas
solitárias no meio das grandes cidades
a conclusão de tudo isso é que nem
urbanismo é muito mais do que um
neologismo urbanismo é exatamente isso
entender qual é o processo cerebral a
qual é a reação que o seu sistema
nervoso tem a você viver numa enorme
cidade dentre outras várias questões
está tratando aqui especificamente a da
solidão então como é que os seus tão
nervoso central como é que ele reage
diante de uma multidão imensa diante de
milhões de pessoas ao seu redor e ao
mesmo tempo a produzindo baixa oxitocina
dopamina e outras substâncias que dão
essa sensação de solidão
ora é a solidão urbana ela é decorrência
de basicamente quatro componentes um dos
componentes é o adensamento nosso
cérebro evoluiu ao longo de milhões e
milhões de anos ea evolução é lenta
durante a maior parte desse processo
evolutivo neuroevolutivo os nossos
ancestrais estavam na savana a nossa
fauna africana
você tinha baixo adensamento eram grupos
pequenos nos colocarem grupos muito
grandes
gera uma sensação de estranheza
você não deveria estar ali
é mais ou menos essa a mensagem que o
seu cérebro está lhe passando um outro
elemento é a baixa interação social
então a você está um grupo enorme de
pessoas mas você está apenas esbarrando
essas pessoas não têm propriamente uma
interação social
além disso o isolamento
então o número de pessoas que nesse
instante por exemplo está cutucando o
smartphone é significativo estou vendo
aqui você acha que nunca tivemos estou
tiver eu estou aqui a fazer uma palestra
para vocês falando de um tema e você
está se isolando a não mas eu estou
conectado então as pessoas estão
confundindo sociabilidade com
conectividade as pessoas se conectam o
seu cérebro ele está acostumado com a
interação olho no olho ele evoluiu para
uma proximidade
nós somos mamíferos primatas nosso
cérebro se desenvolveu para a
convivência em bando em grupos e você
conhece as pessoas do grupo bem ou mal
com muito você conhece então não
acredite que se você tem seis mil
seguidores no instagram a 600 amizade no
facebook que você não está isolado
você está conectado mas do ponto de
vista neurológico você não está
interagindo socialmente
portanto o seu cérebro entende aquilo
com uma situação de isolamento e o pior
de tudo é a recorrência você pode ser
emparedado de vez em quando você pode
estar sob stress vez em quando você pode
ficar sem respirar de vez em quando tem
pessoas que para emagrecer estão fazendo
jejum intermitente eu nunca entendi esse
negócio
então você pode ficar sem comer e de vez
em quando na verdade a questão é a
recorrência e aí tem um outro elemento
muito importante que a inocência nos
ensina que é a plasticidade cerebral
aprender é mudar o cérebro fisicamente
quando você está cantarolando por
exemplo uma música que você sabe decor o
seu cérebro está repetindo a uma
seqüência de disparos de neurônios e
essa sequência de disparos de neurônios
faz você cantar aquela música
toda vez que você tem um processo
recorrente o seu cérebro muda um pouco
só que muitas vezes na interação social
a gente é foca um sentimento até que ele
se transforma numa emoção de fundo que a
emoção de fundo o sistema de ar
condicionado está fazendo barulho
quando eu entrei aqui no auditório onde
tocava quase tudo vazio ao ar
condicionado fazendo barulho
só que você é treinado para ignorar esse
barulho quando você ignora esse barulho
se torna algo de fundo você não presta
atenção nele então a solidão urbana está
se tornando uma emoção de fundo aquilo
que você não presta atenção
mas ela está ali ela está ali e ela está
fazendo efeito
ora o fato é que nós estamos convivendo
com pessoas e grandes massas e em
espaços que são espaços de transição e
não espaços de ação no shopping você
está esbarrando em pessoas que são
grandes desconhecidos
a cidade antiga por exemplo não era
assim a ágora grega o fórum romano eram
espaços de tomada de decisão era onde o
destino da cidade é discutido há onde é
importante conhecer as pessoas
preste atenção a isso aqui é uma emoção
de fundo para você
o desconhecimento que você tem das
pessoas que estão ao seu redor
mesmo em espaços com muita gente
o seu cérebro está percebendo os essa
sensação de não me pertence tem a ver
também com a escala humana só uma lição
básica do le corbusier algumas
construtoras estão oferecendo entre
aspas estúdios inspirados na arquitetura
de navios de submarinos
você vai dizer para você mesmo o seu
cérebro vai dizer
inconscientemente esse lugar não foi
feito para mim não é muito diferente da
rua margarida pensando baião não foi
feita para mim a mais só que agora vamos
aguardar e ter consciência e ela foi
atrás de um futuro melhor para ela a
gente está sufocando essa sensação
ok mas aí o que eu faço
quais são as lições aqui baião poderia
oferecer uma cidade como são paulo por
exemplo biofilia a presença de elementos
naturais reduz o cortisol baixa pressão
ou seja é importante estar próximo da
natureza a cidade de toronto no canadá
tem uma meta daqui 20 anos
todo mundo vai estar a pelo menos no mar
semana 20 minutos de um parque de um
espaço natural permeabilidade
nós temos que enxergar através a peça na
arquitetura do masp por exemplo
este é um espaço de ação em são paulo é
as pessoas se reúnem ali pra atuar
socialmente
isso é muito importante e pensa no
trocadeiro é uma das visões mais
fantásticas de paris
você enxerga através da torre enfel
enxerga a cidade enxerga o céu espaços
de ação a estão sendo criados
então quando você fecha avenida paulista
você transformou um espaço de transição
um espaço de ação genial a idéia é
simples a que pode ser adotada por nós
e aqui ó a igreja do cairo em berlim
destruídos no bombardeio da segunda
guerra mundial
ela foi construída com um monumento para
exaltar a marca alemã se construiu do
lado foi uma igreja modernista
acolhedora a que favorece a reflexão
tem muitas coisas na linha da dos olhos
você não tem que olhar pra cima aquilo é
a escala humana à escala humana é muito
importante
cidades responsivas a gente precisa ir
além das marcas city a cidade não tem
que ser só desperta tem que ser
humanizada aonde eu estou onde estão
outras pessoas que têm o mesmo interesse
que eu tenho onde está o meu grupo no
meio da metrópole
isso é muito importante e exposição
evidentemente a nossa natureza urbana
natureza morta
a gente tem que recuperar isso a gente
tem que resgatar a essa natureza morta
crime que nos cerca
então em síntese não é o que a história
da rua margarida ea cidade de baião pode
ensiná em perdão para são paulo
nós vamos pegar esses elementos são é
uma utopia urbana a permeabilidade de o
filia a despoluição em baião você
enxerga natureza natureza viva você
conhece as pessoas talvez até demais mas
a gente precisa conhecer as pessoas
então se você não sente não se sente
pertencendo
idade você pode estar cercados milhões
de pessoas
você vai se sentir sozinho tutorial
[Aplausos]